[Music]
sonic Fox means a lot of different
things to a lot of different people
they're the greatest Mortal Kombat
player of all time they're a hero to an
often maligned community guess I gotta
at least say is that I'm gay black a
very pretty much everything about public
and hates and the best eSports player
yes there are America's greatest hope in
a genre dominated by the rest of the
world they are an inspiration
they're not what many people expect but
they're everything an esports competitor
should aspire to be we all have a top
here and that's when dobkiss a win Sonic
Fox's story starts out like so many
esports stories that came before their
brother Christian was a Tekken fan and
Sonic Fox just three years old was
mesmerized by it since then they've been
obsessed with fighting games as far as
you come a membered the very first game
I ever saw second dream and I saw my
brothers playing it I thought let us
notice like with my earliest memories
child but all happy to have been three
when I first ever saw a game and like I
can't literally can remember my life
before that that's the very first memory
very first early memories watching
Tekken 3 be played and like just being
astounded by it and then I tried and
fell in love with it and then what'll
come ception came out nice deception
Deadly Alliance was out and I saw my
brother playing that and after they fill
up that wall accompied and ever since
then I just knew that I loved fighting
tournaments came a few years later
though at 13 sonic was playing in
tournaments up and down the East Coast
traveling with her brother to play
Mortal Kombat Soul Calibur and Dead or
Alive among other games and even back
then the Masters took notice and Kyani a
French Soul Calibur Pro took a picture
with Sonic Fox because she related to
their story a young prodigy who may not
have been taken seriously by their peers
but was good enough to challenge the
best as the years went on people learned
what Kyani already knew
sonic Vox was a name to be feared but he
just wanted to that was a very good
reaction by Sonic box jaw what that
prediction it was that a dream I'm not
sure if no it might have been a read cuz
heats app is very fast
so early yes my god yo stream Sonic she
is not OD right now come on but long
before song Fox knew they were a
fighting game God they knew some other
important things about themselves first
they were a furry sonic Fox discovered
their first Sona
a blue Fox when they were around ten
years old as the years went on they went
more and more public with that part of
their identity
so I've always been at first I was
longing simple number two because I grew
up watching Happy Tree Friends and I
always really really liked it I created
my own character for the happy chief and
so seeing and I was like I kind of want
to see this character and a more anthos
style than oh well I'm a fairy and
that's all that happened but I just knew
I have a bunch of friends and family
inside of the community that were really
important to me and I just I kept
sticking with it as I was growing up and
it just became much more and more
powerful the furry community is often
misunderstood while many see it as a
purely sexual thing kind of kink for
many furries it's more about a way of
life a community they can belong to it's
also a way to express yourself through
your for sona an anthropomorphised
animal that becomes an alternate
identity a sort of avatar in the
community people draw therefore sona's
write stories about them and of course
some are able to purchase elaborate
custom fur suits letting them go to
various conventions and meet up as their
first sona and as sonic bugs grew more
comfortable expressing that side of
themself at tournaments it began to
boost their own confidence at first it
was like I thought it was cool second I
eventually stopped caring oh there's
nobody to stop me and then I said kept
getting more and more involved for a
community I just adding word costumes
and stuff to that and exited getting
paid all a bit more so I guess I doing a
couple more cool stuff with it you know
like I just kept progressing more and
more into furry filth
but there's another major facet to Sonic
Fox's identity they're queer I wanna
give a super shout out to all my LGBTQ
plus friends that
[Applause]
Sonic's coming-out process has been
pretty public after all they've lived
most of their life in the public eye and
definitely took me a while to come to
terms with it it didn't have the fence
that I had in high school I definitely
wouldn't have figured it out ever but
when I came to trim to that I was like I
know it was like to have always hid that
feeling that sucked so I don't want
anybody ever to feel that way and I just
want to be me all the time so I started
being really really open with it after I
got really comfortable with myself now
look I want everybody else to be really
comfortable with themselves as well
Sonic initially came out as a gay man
and then later identified themselves as
a non-binary man as for why they do all
this out in the open making sure
everyone knows well it's about making it
as accepted as possible letting everyone
know they're welcome in the fgc how can
I explain it it's like it makes it feel
like I'm no different from anybody else
in a community where it's kind of looked
down upon to be that way you know so
when I do things like that I don't know
I feel good
the thing is when one of the best
fighting game players in the world is a
queer black furry it's a lot easier for
people to see themselves in the
community Sonic Fox's presence and
dominance tells people that there's a
place for them no matter who they are
and they too could be the best because
very quickly Sonic Fox became the best
Sonic's dominus began with injustice
where they burst onto the North American
scene with wins at final round 17 and
CEO 2014 Oh again this could be in is
that an input err our guest
that's Daniel he's dead hop off switch
in sonic Fox sonic classic one first
major that girl has won her first big
box
he's definitely gonna go for super he
wanted it right there 14 I told you ash
up super to make him watch no unpause
the game controller and sonic Fox is
your CEO 2014 champion then came Evo the
biggest fighting game tournaments in the
world big one sec oh no she wanted that
so bad though is one more mix up any
block I push blocked and he gets the way
and there's the DP this could be it bugs
it's gonna take it 6-0 evolution 2014
champion those Grand Finals matches were
many people's first look at Sonic Fox
many saw them as a quiet young kid with
an incredible understanding of the game
as a younger player and I see this a lot
in fighting games in general younger
players who are very talented and very
good they tend to take those risks a lot
more often than you know seasoned
players are even older players so to see
him do well I think Batgirl is a perfect
fit for him things like absolutely
perfect fit for him but Sonic wasn't
just good at injustice around the same
time they played and excelled at dead or
alive
Mortal Kombat
under night fix at the Rio and
skullgirls
that's it girl Seahawks Sonic Fox and
another game is why catalog sonic was a
fighting game prodigy they could pick up
a game figure it out and dominate it in
weeks
the fgc has seen figures like this
before for years justin wong would pop
his head into a new game and win plenty
of early tournaments but the difference
between Justin and Sonic is that
eventually Justin went back to his main
games Sonic Fox went into a game
conquered the competition and remained
on top and a Sonic's trophy shelf grew
it they became more and more confident
with showing more sides of himself to
the crowd Sonic quickly became known for
their trademark hat and tail a sort of
furry calling card people became so used
to seeing Sonic in the Hat that it was a
shock whenever they took it off nobody
in the crowd saw this coming oh look at
the glance from Tekken Master Wu inside
[Laughter]
I don't think we've ever seen that
before we have he hikes we're seeing
Pharaoh man bareheaded human sonic fly
saw his brain would be exposed there but
success breeds haters and sonic Fox had
to brush off their fair share for years
Sonic Fox was the unquestionable best
player in the world when it came to
Mortal Kombat and injustice but to
certain members of the fgc at large that
wasn't good enough
the problem was you know there was
always this reputation that the people
who are good at m'kay weren't really
actually good at fighting games they
were just good and they were lucky that
Street Fighter players didn't play
because clearly they would lose and
stuff like that to some Sonic's
tournament record came with an asterisk
sure they were the best Mortal Kombat
player critics would say but the
competition wasn't real
Street Fighter Marvel vs. Capcom in the
haters eyes those were the legit
fighting games with deep pools of highly
talented players and decade old legacies
[Applause]
meanwhile sonic Fox was playing smaller
games newer games games that to some
weren't as important I felt one crazy
reddit thread I remember back in the day
of someone saying like oh you know sonic
Fox can't play Marvel because they need
a block button which is just crazy
because they were also playing you know
they're playing like schoolgirls at the
time and being incredible and under
night and being incredible
so just none of that made any sense but
it was a way to you know kind of
downplay sonic raucous achievements and
keep pumping up the players that they
liked and knew already it didn't hit
them too hard but it didn't ship away at
their legacy for people looking in from
the outside
it made sonic Fox look like a huge fish
in a small pond so sonic Fox began to
branch out but it wasn't because of the
haters just upset a lot of people at
high level that's like I don't even want
to be the best I don't upset people I
really love Taikan and my main
characters back so we'll see how that
goes but I'm putting in the no time
award to show people that hey I got it
but every game I set my mind to Sonic
Fox finished top eight at the first-ever
Street fortified premier tournament
beating the eventual Capcom Cup champion
knuckle do in the first major tournament
of the year
hit those oh my gosh he's slidin he's
coming at him he's going for the lodge
and he pops off he pops off
sonic box they play Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite the next year barely missing
out on qualifying for the game's first
and only World Finals one trap real
reset all the while sonic was still the
person to beat in NRS games the lowest
they ever placed in a Mortal Kombat X
tournament was fourth and they want
twenty tournaments including of course
two back to back and bow titles to win
twice in two years it's not a feat that
many fighting game players have
accomplished you know some people have
won evo twice over a course of several
years in different games and certainly
that is incredible I think as far as I
know one of the only other players to
have done it was Daigo when Street
Fighter 4 came out in 2009 2010 and that
is this achievement is you know in that
way die go s right it is this show of
dominance as if to say I am sonic box
right saying I am the greatest player to
play these games but the time injustice
to world around Sonic was nearly
unstoppable in the NRS scene 15
tournament wins in a year and a half and
though they missed out on the Evo titles
they still picked up both Pro Series
finals titles earning the last official
tournament victory of the game's life
closing out its era as its true champion
sonic Fox closes out at any second here
and that could be a game not just not
not just like but still in this is a
very tense moment mechanical back what
can it do well the overhead and I don't
too
but all the while there was one more
game that Sonic was excelling at the
game that would truly silence their
haters
[Music]
[Applause]
Dragonball Fighters release was exciting
for fans who wanted their favorite
characters in the game but hyper and its
release really focused on which
legendary fighting game players would
pick it up it brought together people
from you know guilty gear and Street
Fighter and Marvel and even Smash Bros
and of course the NRS community any kind
of fighting game people came in to
Dragon Ball and so you had people really
paying attention to you know from smash
guys like lessons from Marvel's Capcom
guys like Chris G and you know from the
NRS community sonic box sonic tooks DB
FZ almost instantly and made sure that
they were given the respect they deserve
in the game that brought together the FG
c 3o 3o sexist showdown the North
American community rallied around Sonic
box but across the Pacific go Ichi
another fighting game legend was being
hailed as the best in the world and the
pair loved to play into their
international rivalry so yah sony cooks
oh one thing up go Ichi oh my G daddy
pair of ivory from that point on became
like the best rivalry I think takes us
in a fighting game because it's like we
just want to push each other to her
absolutely yes like oh they could ever
ask for somebody in any fighting game to
do for me go Ichi and sonic Fox didn't
have too much in common but there was
one thing that tied them together go
Ichi was known in Japan as the king of
poverty games a classification given to
games that tend to have anime aesthetics
extremely complicated mechanics and of
course low to non-existent price pools
he's played like ever every poverty
anime game that you and I I've never
heard of he's like multi-time champion
and he's actually I heard that he was
like a rhythm game champion
in Japan there's like some rhythm game
in Japan that he's like the best that to
you but there was like one year where
anime Evo held like a bunch of side
tournament and go Ichi I think won like
five titles that Evo or something
go hu was a solid Street Fighter 5
player but he was the god of games that
rarely got their time in the limelight
Dragonball Fighters represented a chance
for both players to dominate in a game
that everyone was paying attention to a
game where no one could say they were
just beating players who weren't good
enough to cut it in the big leagues and
very quickly Sonic Fox and gooey cheese
rivalry became Dragonball Fighters main
event
you know what great job from go Ichi
he called them out and he finished the
job Ted for for the obvious and there it
is that may be curtains and all she
wrote and go week she goes into the
loops final flash and coming after this
energy field and this is gonna be enough
to through the top don't eat see is your
final ground champion what a tremendous
grand finals the guaranteed it's settled
now don't we see is without question the
best in the world look inside a box on
the down all the Rockets abandoned okay
it's time to get up
good luck oh but he's gonna DP in the
bed yes he does and go each sheet snakes
it I'm pretty sure sad if I thought that
was gonna be safe look at that Ichi your
Victor yes he is go Ichi won their first
few sets but sonic [ __ ] caught up fast
winning the next three protectively want
mix up away ladies and gentlemen from
taking this away
sonic your combo breaker 2018 Dragonball
Fighters champion air-to-air you got
under owning box gonna take it away from
you fourth place for going she in the
summit of power you know what safe to
say I think at this point that is gooey
cheese demon oh my god this type of
coochie but that's gonna be it tired
Pollock fault once again defeats coach
in tournaments the table has turned
between these two and he qualifies into
grand finals winner sighs heading into
Evo they were all tied up it's up for
grabs well we got it here winners finals
of evolution lots go eat you one more
time
now sonic boss tag buttons he's too good
in the Scramble the god king of all
scrambled no this is looking absolutely
free right now the sonic buck snap yes
get him outta give me the blue I want to
see you so Pat it really base marking or
does he think to take the other
character bring the character back
okay we take that we take that he gets
the whole thing yes he is healthy make
some hero the extra hell he's summoned
Center on and everything javelin come on
is that actually nothing yes it is sonic
boxing grand finals winners side older
men is excited sonic fox13 oh but with
the Swift win over his teammate Fenric
gucci clawed his way back to grand
finals for a second showdown with his
rival javelin bang energy field
okay one on the board we'll go eat see
looking way better than he did in the
winners finals I will say that
oh god I'm clean air task 4 thoughts on
cars running up
they say I'm plenty of are ya even be
made to vanish with two weights knocked
him down and that might be enough final
flash sonic hogs knowledge no pixel
pixel pixel pixel pixel God Oh ran all
the way up and it's gonna be a reset so
go Ichi climbs his way back into Grand
Finals from the losers bracket goes as a
Grand Finals and annihilate sonic Fox in
the first set right he resets the
bracket three oh it is insane and
everyone thinking holy craps going she's
got this and then sonic boss requests
the other side of the south
yeah the questions on it boss apparently
asked me if there can be a side switch
in between the sets he wants Flair one
knows some people thought that Sonic box
was like maliciously trying to get the
upper hand I don't think that was the
case I think you know it was language
barriers and harmonic box feels more
comfortable on that side but at the end
of the day it ended up completely whole
thing go eat cheese momentum I don't
know it might be a stretch but sign of
us maybe did that just to cool the man
off and you think Oh each eagerly salad
bars like your bro are you serious
like what let's get this going and in
Dragon Balls final match of the night it
was Sonic Fox who personifies it's done
it bucks Oh
we'll finish no and do not tell me we're
going to summit are we gonna summon 2018
he's dead he's done it yes it like I
said it felt great it's not only that I
win in a non NRS Title I beat the best
player in Japan to do it so that's the
very first time I was in Grand Finals
with players from Japan ever and the
fighting game and Evo and I defeated him
too because something of the hard work
that he put him into hard work I played
but very happy to say at that moment
that I was the best Dragon Balls played
Sonic Fox put themselves at the top of a
game played by everyone where the
competition was fierce and no one could
dispute their success that night they
were the best fighting game player in
the world in a world where the top
players tend to be reserved hyper
serious and traditional sonic bugs bucks
the trend by standing apart they stand
as an example that anyone can be a star
anyone can be the best so to have Sonic
Fox who's a gay furry you know very
young and and also african-american or
black I should say who's also black you
know represent the fighting game
community I am a hundred percent for at
CEO 2018 Sonic folks gave their fifth
place Dragon bullfighters medal to a kid
watching them in the crowd and promised
him a first-place medal the next year at
CEO 2019 they made good on that promise
combat neck view with a first-place
metal
that singular moment on its own stands
as an example of what sonic fox means to
the fgc they're an inspiration for
future generation a generation that can
play whatever they want be whoever they
want and still be the best I mean it's
only a good thing right to have someone
like that be our ambassador who's
lifting the trophies and taking the
awards and talking up fighting games it
tells people who might not be part of
those stereotypes who might not
associate with those stereotypes that
they're also welcome they can be whoever
they want to be and love fighting games
and play fighting games and maybe even
be the best fighting game player in the
world well the next year of Dragon Ball
fighters was a little less kind to our
hero they still put up a second-place
finish at Evo after a tense run back
against go eg closets took both sides
I'm blocking both sides now H mystic
ball this is huge
sonic box normal reset the challenge go
Ichi was ready for it he brings them up
this is it drop up keep it simple there
it is go Ichi your Dragon Ball Fighters
2019 Evo champion but instead of being
salty they stood next to their rival and
raised up his hand I want them to get
stronger and I want myself to get strong
because if they don't get stronger how
can I get stronger right like I want
people to push me to my limit I want
people to kill me for silly mistakes and
I want my first I want me to kill them
for their silly mistakes because we will
become better fighting game players if
it could really pushes us also limit
that's another one of the many things
that stand out about Sonic Fox when they
lose they're never off sulking they're
laughing and smiling they're just happy
to be doing what they love playing
fighting games and putting on a show
right after that finals against go ichi
sonic fox walked right over to the
mortal kombat setups and got to work
they were easily the best mortal kombat
player in the world at that point
but that didn't mean victory would be
free Sonic Fox plowed through their
bracket and after a close match with
dragon in the winners finals proceeded
to demolish him 300 in grants to the
flaws blocks down the race to punch one
angel but no other back things up ocean
2019 champion they proved once again
that they were the best mortal combat
player in the world once again no one
could touch their legs they played two
championship caliber top eight
back-to-back second place and one person
the other I can think of very few other
players who can match that Sonic boxes
professional career is only about five
years long but it's easier to forget
that given just how much they've
achieved in that time in just five years
they've assembled a trophy cabinet that
rivals some of fighting games greatest
talents they've become an example of
everything great about the fgc they've
become an ambassador for eSports I think
Sonic Fox is one of the best ambassadors
we could possibly have for the FTC I
love it
right because one of the things that I
want the FCC to be known for to pride
myself on the FTC is the diversity that
we have here they've won over 60
first-place trophies including five evil
world titles they're one of the greatest
fighting game players of all time but
perhaps more importantly they're an
inspiration and that will be their
legacy no matter who I am no matter
where I am no matter what I'm doing with
it's gaming or in the work field I'm
going to be me that's the only thing I
could have asked for to be fine
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages